hey what's up guys my name is a Chan and
welcome back to my opengl series so last
time we talked about vertex buffers
there's a link up there if you haven't
seen that video but there were some
parts that we were missing to actually
get our triangle rendering and
specifically between major parts that we
were missing were vertex attributes and
shaders today we're going to cover
vertex attributes so what what is a
vertex attributes so basically the way
that the OpenGL pipeline works is we've
kind of discussed lightly in the last
episodes and we will have some kind of
in depth video on that in the future but
to put it simply the way that the OpenGL
pipeline works is that we basically
supply our graphics card with data we
store some kind of memory on the GPU
which contains all of the data of what
we want to draw and then we'll use a
shader which is a program that is
executed on the GPU to actually kind of
read that data and display it on the
screen
more or less and typically the way that
we actually draw to your tree is we use
something called a vertex buffer that is
basically a buffer of memory that's
stored on the GPU so when the program
the shader actually starts to read that
vertex buffer it needs to know the
layout of that buffer what is actually
contained in the buffer is just a bunch
of floats which dictate the position of
each vertex do you also have texture
coordinates normals anything else like
that we have to actually tell OpenGL
what is in the memory and how its laid
out because if we don't do that then as
far as opengl can say it's just a bunch
of bytes it's the same as with c++ right
I mean if I write a float and I assign
it something we know that the memory
there is a float because I'm telling say
plus class this is a float if I cost
that to an integer by the boy if I cost
it to an int pointer if I take the
memory address of the flow and cost it
to an end pointer and then dereference
it I'm gonna get something completely
different because it's interpreting the
memory differently that's kind of the
same thing that's going on here we need
to be able to tell OpenGL the first 12
bytes are three floats four bytes per
flow and that is my position the next
eight bytes after that are my texture
coordinates I've got one float for X and
one flip for Y or u U and V if you want
to call it like that we need a way to be
able to tell it in gel this is the
layout of my memory and that is exactly
what this whole vertex attribute pointer
thing can do for us there's a function
in OpenGL called geo vertex a true
pointer that's what we're going to be
taking a look
today from the shade aside you also need
to match the layout that you define on
the CPU side on the surplus class site
as well and when we actually introduced
traders in the next episode we'll take a
look at a basic example of what that
looks like as well and again I'm just
starting off with really basic examples
so that you can see what it is like in
its simplest form but as the series goes
on we are obviously going to ramp it up
and make it way more complicated I'm
just kind of starting you guys off
gently all right without just rambling
on further let's take a look at the code
so from last episode we have basically a
float array of positions here you can
send it the way that I've kind of
divided it is that each line here is an
actual vertex right so we'd have three
vertex positions we have three vertices
this is the x coordinate this is the y
coordinate of our vertex on our spring
now before I go on I just really wanted
to find what I mean by vertex because
people seem to get pretty confused with
that and also use that word incorrectly
a vertex has nothing to do with the
position right and vertex is just a
point that is on your geometry the way
that most people think about them
visually obviously is by its position so
if I draw you a triangle you'll be like
ah three vertices but vertices don't
vertices are not positions right a
vertex is not a position a vertex can
contain way more than just a position so
if you tell me hey I have a vertex it's
0.5 0.5 that doesn't tell me anything
right because you're kind of implying
that I mean vertex position and yes a
lot of people do user like that but
that's not exactly correct because the
vertex can contain way more data than
just a position although it does usually
contain a position so I just wanna make
that clear when I say vertex position
that's what I really mean I'm not gonna
just if I actually say that one vertex I
mean the whole blob of data that makes
up that vertex which again could include
the position texture coordinates normals
colors by normals tangents all of this
kind of stuff right that could all be in
a single vertex so just the position if
you're just referred to the position you
should really call it positional vertex
position so that's why I've got this
float here as kind of positions not just
vertices because at the moment they're
just positions although when I add stuff
to them I really probably
anyway so we have these three vertices
here and then we're generating a buffer
binding and then actually putting this
kind of or I should say copying these
positions into this actual buffer that
we've defined here by just specifying a
pointer to them and how big they are and
that's it that's all we're doing so far
so again OpenGL has no idea that if you
look at this code we can clearly see
okay so we have two floats per vertex
and that is the X&Y position right
OpenGL doesn't know that it might seem
obvious to you because you're looking at
this code you're like well how can open
gel not know that but what if I suddenly
introduced a third kind of coordinate
right so in other words what if I want a
three dimensional coordinate system
instead of two dimension like we've kind
of got here what if I do this well then
suddenly you know how does OpenGL know
that I've actually got three vertices of
a three kind of dimensional coordinate
system instead of just one two three and
then kind of four and a half I guess of
just two coordinates right because if I
was to rearrange this code
well then suddenly it looks like we
actually have more than three vertices
here if you kind of stick to the kind of
two-dimensional rule right so what I'm
kind of getting at is that we need to
tell OpenGL out layout and that's what
we're about to do so if we scroll down a
little bit once we kind of bind the
buffer and we fill it with dot e you
don't have to do this before you fill it
with Dada you don't have to do it after
you can do it whenever as long as the
buffer is actually bound that is when we
can tell OpenGL what the layout of our
buffer actually is and the main way that
we do that if I just open up my favorite
documentation website here doc so GL
there are two kind of lines of code that
we have to ride the most important one
though is GL vertex at rib pointer which
is right over here right I'll click on
the jail for link and we can see what we
have here so it takes quite a few
parameters in by the index size type
normalized stride and pointer let's go
through them really quickly so the index
is the index of the share info text
attribute to be modified again this
doesn't make much sense if you don't
know how this works basically the way
that our shader reads all this is by an
index it's a picture it is almost like
an array but the types in the array
might be different so this is an index
as to which attribute you're actually
referring to all of these things by the
way uphold attributes
when I mentioned that a vertex is made
up of more than just position right
might be position texture coordinates
normals colors whatever each one of
those like a position is an attribute a
color is an attribute a texture
coordinate is an attribute a normal is
an attribute they're all attributes so
this index is just telling us hey what
index is this attribute at the reason I
say this is because typically if we have
like a position for example at index 0
we need to be able to refer to it as
index 0 so let's just picture this right
I have three kind of attributes I have
position texture coordinate and normal I
need to be able to say that I want my
position to be at index zero my texture
ponent been at index 1 and my normal to
be at index 2 so that when I kind of
start reading stuff from the shader side
from the GPU side and I go into that
buffer I can simply reference them by
hey index 2 placed and I know that that
will be my normal because I've kind of
defined that layout that's what an index
is it's just the index of that actual
attribute in your buffer size here can
be a bit misleading it's the number of
components per generic vertex attribute
you can see that it says here clearly
that it must be one two three four so
again this size has nothing to do with
bytes or like actual how much memories
of this occupies it is it's basically
the count so what I mean by that is when
we specify the type here such as for our
actual vertex positions GL float this is
how many floats were providing so here
clearly we have two floats per vertex so
this size will be true because we're
basically providing a two component
vector that represents our position if
we switch to that kind of 3d coordinate
system as I mentioned earlier we would
be we would be setting it to three
because we have three floats for this
for this actual attribute all right so
type as I just explained is basically
the type of data that we're providing
jail flirt is what we want normalized
this is a little bit more tricky we
don't really need to worry about this
particularly if we do if we're dealing
with floats because they already are
normalized but basically this is used
for let's just say that we're specifying
a byte that is between 0 and 255 because
that's our color value that needs to be
normalized to be between 0 and 1 as a
floor in our actual shader and this is
what will actually do it for us so
basically this isn't
sample of something that you can do
yourself on the CPU side but you can
also let open gel them for you if you're
lazy or if you're kind of if you just
want open gel to do it for you so we'll
be setting this to false or specifically
GL false because normalized is actually
a GL boolean which is just an integer
all right stride and pointer this is
where a lot of people get a little bit
confused so I wanted to be clear on this
stride is as the documentation states
the byte offset between consecutive
generic vertex attributes this is worded
in not sure why they why they worded it
like this but basically what the stride
is is the amount of bytes between each
vertex so again in our example now kind
of made-up example if we have a position
we have a texture coordinate and we have
a normal let's just say the position is
a three component vector then the
texture coordinate is a two component
vector two floats and then the normal is
is three components once again right so
we have three floats that's 12 bytes
plus two floats for the for the texture
coordinate that's another eight bytes or
on 20 bytes and then another 12 bytes
for the normal so 32 bytes that is our
stride because it's basically this site
the size of each vertex the reason this
is important is because if opengl and
the reason it's called stride as well is
because we if we want to jump from one
vertex to the next so for example i want
to look up index number one so from zero
zero is our first vertex i want to jump
to our second vertex which is index
number one i need to go plus 32 bytes
into the buffer so we have a pointer to
the beginning of our buffer and I go 32
bytes into it I should be at the very
start of the next vertex that is what
the stride is so just remember that the
pointer on the other hand is as this
stay it's an offset of the first
component of the I don't even want to
read this to be honest it's so confusing
pointer is a pointer into the actual
attribute so this is already inside the
space of the vertex right so you're just
pretend don't worry about how many
vertices you have anymore
pretend you only have
vertex I have one vertex and inside
there I have position texture corner and
normal what is the offset of each of
those in bytes right so for position the
offset will be zero because the very
first the very first byte of our buffer
the very first byte of our actual vertex
is the position right then we go 12
bytes forward and we and we reach the
beginning of the texture coordinate so
for my texture quarter attribute this
value would be 12 because 12 bytes into
it is where we begin and finally 8 bytes
into that we get to the vertex normal
right so 20 bytes from the beginning is
my vertex normal format so for my vertex
normal attribute 20 would be the value
of this pointer now instead of just
writing generic things like 0 12 and 20
because that can get a bit confusing and
not only that but if you actually
rearrange your layout or something like
that you'll have to reach out
recalculating or manually
there are macros and kind of well it
really is a macro called offset of
actually German demonstrated that in the
arrow operator if you guys watch my
arrow operator video which is should
because it's important for C++ I
actually kind of demonstrated offset of
I actually wrote it myself instead of
using a macro but the library actually
the C++ library in the state library
provides you with an offset of macro
which you can use to actually find the
offset of something in a struct or class
so you can use things to kind of lie
same with stride as well you can use
kind of macros and stuff like that to
automate this stuff for yourself so that
you don't have to just be putting values
like 12 or 32 as I said to the stride
manually I'm just explaining to you what
actually should be but just hopefully
this explains the entire kind of bird X
a three-pointer function - because again
it's something that can be confusing if
you're just starting out but it is
actually really simple make sure that
it's correct because if you get even one
byte kind of out of place here you're
gonna get weird artifacts probably in
your rendering or just a black screen or
something like that okay so back here in
our code we can finally use this now so
what I can do is with the buffer
actually bound that's important I'm just
going to write GL vertex at rib pointer
all right so again first parameter is
the
index now this is a really simple case
as I mentioned earlier we just have
positions so first of all we only have
one vertex attribute so we only need to
call this function once because we're
way to specifying a single attribute eyo
the index of course will be zero because
it's the first attribute the size
remember the size is the component count
not anything to do with actual size and
bytes so how many floats represent this
specific vertex attribute to somewhere
right - next we have well this one way
next we have the type so this is going
to be the type of data that we have here
clearly as it floats so we're going to
type in GL float next we have whether or
not we want them to be normalized no
they're already flows they're already in
the space that we want them to be so
jail false next we have the stride now
as I mentioned the stride is the amount
of bytes that we have between each
vertex so this is our first vertex
second vertex third vertex clearly the
stride is the size of two floats right
so what we could write is just eight
basically we could also write sizeof
flirt times two and that's probably our
best way to kind of automate that so to
speak and make it as easy to read as
possible here because we're not dealing
with something like a struct or anything
like that eventually when we have more
than just kind of a position per vertex
and we'd start introduce things like
that your coordinates and normals we
will have a struct that makes up a
single vertex and in that sense we could
just pass in the size of that struct as
the stride and that would be fine but
for now size of flow times two is how
much you need to go forward to get to
the second vertex and just that just to
make that super clear because we only
have one attribute here it's the amount
that we need to go forward to get to the
second vertex not the second attribute
okay that's kind of what this next
parameter is the pointer now keep in
mind you can see here that it's actually
a pointer it's taking in a pointer not a
number so this might be a little bit
confusing but it is still just a number
because remember pointers are numbers if
you don't understand pointers fully
watch my video on pointers up there
because that's gonna clear so much up
for you so since this particular
attribute is the first and in this case
only attribute this is just going to be
zero and you can just
something like that if we had another
attribute for example let's just say
texture coordinate kind of started here
or something like that then we would
actually have to pass in the offset to
that texture coordinate which would be 8
bytes so we could just write a it like
that if you try and do that you're going
to get an error here because we're
trying to pass in 8 and it needs to be a
constant word pointer the way you fixed
that is you just cast 8 to a constant
word pointer my seem a bit dodgy or
whatever but it's totally fine that's
what you meant to do and of course if
you were doing this properly and you had
a real kind of application or engine or
something like that you would probably
have a struct to actually define your
vertex and then you could just use the
offset of macro to figure out what this
is for you instead of just writing 8 or
something like that because that that's
not a good way to go anyway of course
for us it's zero there you go that's it
that's how you use this function in this
case and it should work just fine but
wait there is always always something
that I forget that you need to write to
actually make this work
I always forget this when I start
writing up in jail stuff from scratch
because obviously if you're kind of like
me you don't typically write code like
this often because this is something
that you kind of do the first time when
you're setting up a new engine and then
you forget about it but there is one
more line of code that we need otherwise
we are just going to get a black screen
and that is we need to actually enable
that vertex attribute so back in our
documentation here really wish that this
documentation actually said something
about enabling or having to call enable
in fact I don't remember who does yeah
it does at the end it says to enable or
disable a generic vertex attribute array
all GL enable vertex attrib array so if
we go to this function you'll see what
this does is it enables it say blah blah
but basically we take in this is the
function we're interested in we
basically just take your me index the
index of the generic vertex attribute to
be enabled or disabled so back in our
code I like to do this before I do the
pointer it doesn't really matter
Open GL of course is a state machine
it's not like it's going to check to see
if it's enabled and then not do this if
it's not it doesn't matter like that you
can call it any way you like as long as
your actual buffa is bound so we're
gonna call GL enable vertex a shrimp
array and then the index we want to
enable which is 0 okay and that is it
these two lines of code are all you need
to do in this case to tell OpenGL what
the layout of our buffer is and
theoretically if we had a shader
which we're going to have in the next
episode we be able to finally see our
triangle and spring going up here it's
going to remove this little error here
there's extra kind of float that I added
just for demonstration and that's it
so basically to summarize this is the
code that we've written today I hope you
guys enjoy this video if you did you hit
that like button you can also go and
join my discord a discord or confidence
re the channel become such discord which
is just basically a community of people
talking about stuff like this so you can
discuss the episode there or you can
leave a comment in the comment section
below if you prefer to do it that way I
really do recommend you join the discord
though there's a great community of
people where you can ask questions about
everything that you kind of see in these
videos as well as you know get help with
your code not working or stuff like that
so definitely join up there if you
really want to support the series and
you want to see more videos and you want
to see videos early and get a bunch of
other kind of rewards as well as I've
actually started doing a hangout a
one-hour hangout with all of the patrons
on a specific tier where we just
basically talk about stuff for an hour
just did one yesterday went really well
so definitely join up there if you're
interested in that patreon for such the
channel really does help support the
series and make sure that I can kind of
keep making these videos as much as
possible next time we're gonna ride some
shaders is probably gonna be quite a
lengthy episode because there is
actually going to be quite some code we
need to set up to actually get shaders
to compile on link in OpenGL but once we
kind of get that down we'll finally have
our triangle on the screen so it should
be really exciting I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]